Hi, I'm Richard Bartrem, Vice President Communications for WestJet.
Today, we're announcing the easing of restrictions on pets in the cabin.
We recognize that a growing number of our guests wanna travel with their extended family...
...and we're proud to be the first airline to offer this type of service.
WestJet's new service, "Furry Family", now allows for any type of animal...
...that fits safely on board.
What's more, we will no longer require animals to be kept in the kennels...
...while they're travelling with us.
After all, they're part of the family.
WestJet's in-flight crews have received special training...
...on how to care for the diverse family members we'll now be welcoming on board.
And don't worry, our lavatory is a bit modified to meet the needs of our special guests.
So if you are looking to travel with your pet, whatever it is,...
...learn more about our new program at westjet.com/furryfamily.
Happy April Fools' from your friends at WestJet!
Thanks for playing along.
Please visit us at westjet.com/furryfamily for additional April Fools' savings.